My name is Eldrick Jacobs.
I've been making and repairing hats
for about three-plus years.
Today I'll be repairing a hat
that is approximately 70-plus years old
while maintaining its character.
First, I'm going to deconstruct the hat.
We use a seam ripper,
and then we use snippers.
The felt is in really great condition,
but we have to be very
careful to make sure
that we don't poke any holes into the felt
or rip something that needn't be ripped.
This hat belonged to my
client's grandfather.
And when he passed, he
passed it down to his father.
We're going to maintain the character
and patina of the hat and the hole.
The client would like to keep the hole
to maintain the continuity
from generation to generation.
The hat has a story,
and he wants to tell that
story as he wears it.
Next, I'm going to clean the felt.
I use a little bit of alcohol
and a little bit of water.
And then we use a hat brush
to brush away any debris
that may be present on
the surface of the felt.
So, the alcohol does two things.
It dissolves a little bit
of the bioresin that's inside of the felt,
making it a little bit more pliable
and more easy to work with,
and then it gets rid of any bacteria
that may be present on
the surface of the felt
and, likewise, any mold
that may be present.
And then we use the sponge
to get a little bit deeper into the felt.
For the hat band, we spray
it with alcohol again,
and this allows me to go over it
with another sponge to really sort of
clean up the hat band
and the loose threads.
We really work to keep it
in its original condition.
We want it, like the felt,
to maintain the character
that it has gained over
those years of wear.
After we do that, we take snippers
and we snip any loose threads.
Then we turn our attention
to reblocking the felt.
Reblocking is the most crucial
part of remaking a hat.
We take the felt and we
heat it up with some steam,
and then we stretch it over a block.
We are choosing a block that'll give us
the circumference of the client's head.
What we're doing here is creating
the basic shape that we
want to give the hat,
called an open crown.
And then once we have it
stretched over the block,
we'll grab a hatter's
knot and a pusher downer,
which is the tool that we
use to take the hatter's knot
to the bottom of the hat block.
Here is where we are creating
the 90-degree break angle
between the crown and the felt.
The hat would be irreparable
if the felt itself was
starting to disintegrate,
particularly around the break line.
That would create an issue
for reblocking the hat.
I'm using a brim cutter,
and it allows for us
to decide how wide or how
short we want the brim.
This brim has to be regulated
down a half an inch.
The general shape will stay the same,
but we are making sure
that the hat frames my
client's face nicely.
And then I'll use a fine-grit sandpaper
to really refine the edge.
In the brim-cutting process,
you don't always get the cleanest edge,
so the sandpaper allows for us
to really create sharp edges on the hat.
And finally, we will create a sweatband.
We cannot reuse the old sweatband.
All we have left is the reed.
And so we have to replace the sweatband
with a new piece of leather.
The sweatband is critically important
to maintaining the integrity of the hat.
It really holds the hat together.
But more importantly,
it allows for a barrier
between the wearer's
forehead and the felt itself.
Hatters can do a lot of things,
but getting sweat out of felt
is quite a difficult feat.
And then, finally, we
shape the crown of the hat.
We use steam again.
Steam really allows for
the felt fibers to open up.
There are two material
components that make up the felt:
there's the individual fur fibers,
and then there is the bioresin.
Felt without the bioresin
would be very flimsy
and not have very much structure to it.
We are really opening that
up and softening it a bit
so that we can get the desired shape.
I'm excited about this
particular restoration,
and I think that my client
will be over the moon
and overjoyed that he has a hat
that looks and feels like
his grandfather's hat
and also has the patina and the character
that comes with a 70-plus-year-old hat.
The only reason this hat would need
to be brought back into our shop
is if we need to do hat maintenance,
particularly with the sweatband.
In general, this hat will last
as long as my client
wants to wear the hat.